there's also a huge
discussion behind the veteran movement
and that's the next subject that we're
our second episode we profile this
organization that's funding grants for
veterans to seek psychedelic experiences
it's an organization called vets and we
followed a couple of veterans over the
border to Mexico because these
psychedelics are not legal here in in
the country for which they fought but
I've heard tremendous treatments are
being done there really really
incredible facilities they really are
and these are men who are in some cases
taking up to 20 pills a day they go to
Mexico for this very um meticulous
lengthy treatment I mean it's a week
long but after one series of treatments
they don't take any pills again I mean
after one experience I mean it's it's
extraordinary um and we have a clip of
of that portion of your special let's
take a look at
that
what
lose here yeah he was right
[Music]
there
yeah I
mean men herb the one who was undergoing
the treatment is a Green Beret former
Green Beret and moose was a former Navy
SEAL and these are me men who were
trained to be our elitist Warriors who
were trained for war and to bury their
emotions and here they were after this
treatment just allowing themselves to be
vulnerable and embracing each other and
it was such a profound moment when these
veterans were finally I think able to
just release all that they' been
carrying and I witnessed it myself me
again these are men who have been
prescribed loads of medication and after
one series of treatments they no longer
take anything but a multivitamin in some
[Music]
cases